the father of Molly Tibbets the
University of Iowa student found dead
last month says attempts to use the
killing to promote an anti-immigrant
agenda or heartless despicable and
shameful in an opinion piece the Des
Moines Register Rob tippet says quote
please leave us out of your debate allow
us to grieve in privacy and with dignity
he also said those exploiting her death
hold views Molly considered profoundly
racist Molly Tibbets father told CBS
News she would want people to turn away
from venal and petty impulses and work
toward harmony to knowingly ferment
discord among races is a disgrace to our
flag he wrote in the Des Moines Register
Saturday it incites fear in innocent
communities and lends legitimacy to the
darkest most hate-filled corners of the
american soul an undocumented Mexican
immigrant has been charged with Molly
Tibbets murder before her body was found
August 21st Rob Tibbets told us he and
his daughter shared an unbreakable bond
she was the best man at my wedding
she gave an unbelievable toast she told
me I was her best friend how did that
feel it was pretty nice do I feel that
way too in the register Rob Tibbett said
he has a stepdaughter and grandchildren
who are Latino who Molly loved dearly
that means I'm Hispanic I am African I
am Asian I am European Tibbets wrote my
blood runs from every corner of the
earth because I am American his op-ed
was published the day after the same
newspaper printed an opinion piece by
Donald Trump jr. the president's son
blamed Democrats and lacks border
policies for Tibbets death a position
echoed by the president they charged an
illegal alien in the murder of a college
student Molly
Tibbits last week Iowa residents
including mr. Tibbets received a robo
call purporting to be from a white
nationalist group about Tibbets murder
calling for all Mexicans to be deported
but in his op-ed Robert Tibbets urged
Americans to turn against racism in all
its ugly manifestations both subtle and
overt let's listen not shout
let's build bridges not walls
Robert Tibbett said seeing the nation
come together for John McCain's memorial
inspired him to write I was
communicating with him yesterday and he
wanted to stress how vice president Mike
Pence has been there for the family he
stressed the vice president's deep
affection and compassion he also said in
his piece that he appealed to
politicians to stop mentioning Molly in
pushing forward their agendas and he
said that they graciously stopped yeah
and even when he said to the Hispanic
community my family stands with you and
offers its heartfelt apology that he
would take the time to reach out to the
Hispanic community I know you spent a
lot of time with the family you told me
this morning that not a day goes by that
you don't think about Molly she was a
wonderful girl yeah I can't imagine what
it must be like to be a parent and have
to deal with all of this political stuff
on this side we're dealing with a greed
for your daughter I mean it's just
extraordinary hopefully we can give them
the piece and that's a very powerful
statement he made